[Music]
i remember my first experience of seeing
this amazing production of art that was
different than what i had seen and it
was such a personal expression by the
person making it they may or may not
have had language they may or may not
have been able to communicate with me
but they're making this work that's
really you know a window into their soul
when you ask someone who's been
disenfranchised their entire life to
tell me your story it's amazing how the
door opens
[Music]
creative growth art center is the oldest
and largest center for artists with
disabilities in the world when we were
founded the idea of disability then
was so radically different than what it
is now
we didn't come out of a hospital setting
or we didn't come out of a vocational
training program we came out of some
artists getting together
in a home in oakland putting paint on a
table in the garage and just saying this
is what artists do and this is how we
can change the social fabric
from those kind of humble beginnings we
now serve 162 artists with disabilities
in our studio every week
it's a very big space within that you'll
find almost every possible expression of
visual art you'll see the rug making
area the wood shop the ceramic studio
the fashion area the painting and
drawing area and everyone's working
together and everyone can see each other
it's different than most places and
some people don't believe it
some people think like you must have
doctors and you must have all these
other things how do you deal with the
the studio every day it's like no you
know art is the common language
and a lot of our folks don't verbalize
or speak or they speak sign language but
art is the language that moves us
forward
this is called the oil red sea number
one
red is the only color i can see
you look at work of an artist like dan
miller you know he's pretty much
non-verbal his mother tried to encourage
him to speak by telling him how to spell
words when he was a boy every night and
he never spoke them until he started to
draw them
the white
go
click
click
click
look at an artist like monica valentine
she takes pins
and she takes sequins and colored beads
and she strings those together on the
pin and she puts them into styrofoam
forms to form these optically charged
sculptures
when you realize that monica has
prosthetic eyes and can't see color or
see anything it moves into this whole
other
we want their own voice we want it as
pure and personalized as it can be
and 45 years later it continues to work
how's that building coming along pete
it's looking good
the record of success that creative
growth has is phenomenal it's off the
charts in terms of what an art school or
any other sort of enterprise would
consider to be acceptable
we have three artists with work in the
museum of modern art permanent
collection in new york and the san
francisco museum of modern art
collection and this year we have the
first two people with developmental
disabilities that work in the venice
biennale
the venice biennale is the most
important prestigious by invitation only
exhibition in the world
their work is sought after you know a
piece is done and there's a waiting list
rosina i haven't even said hello to you
yet today how are you to be able to work
at a place like this is beyond anything
i had hoped for
i get to work with phenomenally talented
people and and to see how they negotiate
the day every day how they get around
obstacles how they continue to say yes
when everyone is telling them no that's
an amazing thing that's a life lesson i
get reminded of every single day
you